all right good let's go next to
why don't we go to um let's go to
javi from from where where is
from north carolina javi from north
carolina you're on the air
hey david can you hear me yes i can
okay awesome so um i
basically am pretty worried and
terrified that 2022 and 24
are going to be a bloodbath for the
democrats i just kind of wanted to lay
out my case why
and i get your thoughts on it sure
so you know i just the
i think to start with the fact that we
were unable to
easily and clearly defeat um
an incompetent [ __ ] like trump in 2020
and the fact that it was as close as it
was that the republicans picked up seats
in itself i thought was
a pretty bad sign yep i feel
like the um
i feel like the right has done a good
job
especially over the last year and i feel
like
they may be effective in doing this
going forward at tying
the left like the democrats to
um a lot of cultural issues that are bs
that that can be appealing to appealing
to
sort of non-partisans or apolitical
people so like telling the democrats
to cancel culture or um
you know just political correctness and
identity politics and all that stuff
and there i feel like their party has
that like they're shifting into a more
establishment
uh into a more anti-establishment party
at least the aesthetics are even if
they're not on the policy but i feel
like policy is
is really starting to matter less and
less these days
yeah and um and also
i just feel like the fact that on the
left i feel like we are
really having a civil war and the right
is not
i feel like the right wing base is
pretty united behind trump it's only
like the dc
um politicians and media people that are
having the civil war but
even on the left our civil war isn't
just establishment left versus
populist left like even in the populist
left we have with like you know
jimmy dore and glenn greenwald and
everyone fighting against
other like you know progressives
on the left and stuff like that and i
just feel like all this is creating the
perfect storm
okay so yeah yeah that's that's a ton of
stuff so i'll just mention a few things
one is that i think the i'll go kind of
go backwards the infighting on the left
it's not clear to me that it's really
having electoral repercussions at this
point in time
because in the end you've got a lot of
people who
are very loud but they don't vote
regardless like they're not voting
either way so it kind of doesn't matter
whether they are in disagreement with
what's going on in the democratic party
because either way
they're just they're they're tweeting
but they're not actually voting that's
part of it
another part of it is that um i i think
that
we you were right in being sort of
concerned about how difficult it was to
defeat trump in the end
and barely won the senate did democrats
and
lost some seats in the house but i think
that there's a unique situation
2024 i'm not even going to think about
until after we get 2022.
for 2022 if it simply ends up being a
referendum on
did joe biden get the economy back to
sort of where it was before the pandemic
did joe biden deal with vaccination well
did joe biden
get stimulus done did joe biden get some
other legislative accomplishment
you may see a reversal of the normal
trend which is
one party wins the white house and then
two years later loses the house
and or senate you may actually see
democrats do really well
in november of 2022. i think it's too
soon to know
and and and i think we we have to wait
and see but i think it's completely
plausible democrats do fine in 2022.
okay yeah well you know i just think
biden won't get enough done to
energize or to satisfy the progressive
left and
and keep them energized to come out in
2022
and then the i guess sort of the last
point that i missed was i just feel like
2022 alone is going to be a blood left
because of the gerrymandering that's
going to come
after the the census as the republicans
control the state legislators
they're going to redraw the districts to
favor them and uh
and yeah that's a real issue that's a
reality and the
and the electoral map for 2024 even
there's more votes that are shifting
towards
texas and florida you know state for
bleeding more republicans so
that those are just that's just why i'm
pretty concerned about that
all right well we're going to follow it
all but i uh i think your concerns are
reasonable and and we will have plenty
of time to discuss for sure i appreciate
the call
thank you david all right thanks
everybody who called i unfortunately
need to uh
hang it up there but we will take calls
again and i hope to hear from you
next time today's episode is sponsored
by bluechew
a unique online service delivering the
same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
in a
chewable form and at a fraction of the
cost and they're giving my audience an
entire month's
supply for free take a short quiz on the
blue chew website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription and the
medication goes
right to your home in a discreet package
no driving to the doctor's office
having a possibly awkward conversation
waiting in line at the pharmacy
bluechu replaces the entire process with
a few
clicks and way less expensive and all of
blue chews tablets are made
in the united states so if you think you
could benefit from an extra boost of
confidence
go to bluechew.com the link is under
this video and they'll give you an
entire month's supply for
free when you use promo code pacman just
pay five dollars for shipping